il faut que je raconte qui vient
d'arriver là je sors du train je suis
gare du nord je vous jure il ya une
fille elle est magnifique elle passe
devant moins comme ça moi je regarde
juste six mois tu es magnifique ça
diraient qu'on aille boire un verre je
vous jure allait passer comme ça moi ma
fille je suis désolé je parle pas
français
mais moi je suis contre le coup j'ai pas
compris hein mon gars je les fais un
sari
2022 les fier sont bizarres 2001 des
laitiers font un truc n'était pas au
courant ça elle met des fossiles
organisée ce truc mais moi je
connaissais pas je n'étais pas au
courant m elle met des fossiles c'est
des faux cils quand t'es pas au courant
c'est dangereux la semaine dernière je
vais chez une meuf ya pas que ça
existait un j'arrive chez elle je rentre
et là je vois posé sur un meuble des
cils
j'ai commencé à paniquer jeux musique tu
étais à la cancer des cils
psychopathe et qui fait si la tue les
gens elle prend leur site j'ai commencé
à pratiquer je regarde sur internet
j'écris à quoi ça sert les styles je
vois que ça sert à protéger de la
poussière pour pas que ça rende dans les
yeux mais qu'at elle fait quoi et que ça
l'est mais en face de moi que j'étais un
beau regard de la nandrolone en
tête je voulais montrer que mais si
lisez ténue j'étais là oh la la la
poussière ici un vraiment oui basse a
prêché comédien je reste dans juste
excuse moi je parlais dans la salle de
bain pour enlever la poussière bio et
vas-y je vais dans la salle de bain la
joie des boîtes de six sorties jeudi
s'cusez moi c'est quoi ça un binôme et
ça c'était faux cils sepa débris si
c'est comme ça que j'ai là c'était
possible c'est pas déprécier leurs
gardes la lafa un truc
elle avait des cils à scratch
2022 normal je parlais qu'une mauvaise
on s'est dit on comme ça toi tu discutes
excuse-moi ya ton s'il tombe elle te dis
merci elle sera pot de colle de son sac
c'est n'importe quoi